[Musique]
paul taille fine
pourtant journalises m'en sur trois
singes récurrentes et l'argumentation
bureau franchement la jeunesse m'a
fasciné mais la photo il y avait un
appel à l hp puis finalement je vais
finir sur un renforcement je vais
l'appeler sultan mois signé un contrat
tu as la conférence de québec que tirent
les musulmans
[Musique]
réussi à faire la gueule l'émission
finale du journal ça continue comme ça
et là un moment d une pénurie que
journaliste on m'a enseigné en tout le
monde a écrit hier collectant des comme
ça que j'ai fait du jour navire suis
alors avec la photographie combiner les
deux que la primo
[Musique]
mais l'armada les talibés la guerre je
suis allé à l'armée alors gt2 à la
photographe de droit de mentir aux
ventes et au score et puis à la piste
le tout le globe and mail la finance je
pense tu es forcément et avait beaucoup
de magazines on touche est un petit
chien
mais
hélas un moment donné on me demandait
aussi d'enseigner à l'université
victoria alors que tu as enseigné par
incision
j'ai voyagé beaucoup pour le journal
surtout doublement trop tard je suis
allé à chypre pour la guerre civile 4 le
royal 22e régiment et aider à chypre
leur revenait de chip et on m'a signé
avec les suivre la reine à partir de
montréal ont toutes ces choses là
pupilles entre eux ça il y avait 30 ans
de mandature
on me permettra aux petits était d'aller
à la porte de la résidence du premier
ministre filmé alors quand tu sors tu es
bon tu as fait des photos fait qu'un
jour je me suis sentie trahie fraser
[Musique]
j'ai appris à connaître et faire
connaître premier ministre mackenzie
king que ce qui a pu les lire plus tôt
je suis devenu chef d'agrès faut
remonter au score durant la crise
d'octobre m'a donné ça me semblait
épuisé pour ta 24 heures par jour 7
jours semaine la crise
j'ai fait des entrevues sur la nuit et
en musique avec un drapeau haïtien du
terme
et c'est la faute au journal ampli qui
lie la scène pour que le lecteur puisse
comprendre
apprendre à avoir des plages aider à
réaliser quand on réalise un projet en
une satisfaction personnelle du devoir
bien accompli fait encore de la photo
beaucoup moins contre x jeudi deux
journaux par jour
on peut pas savoir couverts la politique
et de laisser tomber sur comme ça être
vieux c'est pour petites gens qui n'ont
pas capable de faire il ya un dicton en
anglais qu ignorer notre cci
[Musique]